the way he was taken was not the
america i know like our own government
basically kidnapped
my dad and i was it terrified me
early on a sunday morning in late may
jose garcia was walking to his car to
grab a coffee mug when several armed
agents
in bulletproof vests approached and told
him he was
under arrest they just grabbed me by the
shoulders
then i asked them can you please let me
talk to my daughter my wife
they said no and i started screaming to
natalie
i started hearing him scream out for my
name and
so i ran out like three agents stopped
me
didn't identify themselves i didn't know
who they were natalie garcia
eventually realized that the agents who
arrested her father were with
immigration and customs enforcement
ice his arrest was part of an ice sweep
that had picked up 162 people including
at least
eight green card holders like garcia and
i
had never expected ice to take my
parents because my dad has legal status
her dad was a lawful permanent resident
who'd lived in southern california for
more than 50 years
and raised children grandchildren and
great grandchildren there
i come to america for the american dream
and build a family as well you can
obviously get whatever you want when you
work hard
ice targeted garcia based on a 17 year
old domestic violence misdemeanor which
he says happened when a neighbor called
the police after overhearing an
argument between him and his wife the
courthouse didn't retain any documents
describing the incident in any further
detail but garcia's guilty plea in 2001
made him technically eligible for
deportation
at the time of garcia's arrest national
attention was focused on the family
separation crisis
at the u.s mexico border protesters
railed against the trump administration
action that separates children from
parents accused of violating immigration
laws
i have put in place a zero tolerance
policy
for illegal entry on our southwest
border
and soon garcia's case began to receive
national attention
natalie found herself standing at the
center of a media storm
and defending her father they should not
even be separating families
i became the poster child for this whole
entire
situation i'm a private person in
general being
in front of the camera it was never
something that i wanted to do
but the more that i was the more that i
know it was helping my father
she told me that she was going to get me
out of there
and i believed in her and i know she was
going to do it
one way or the other the judge granted
jose's
case during the very first hearing a
highly unusual move
according to his los angeles-based
immigration attorney
mackenzie matkins the fact that mr
garcia's case was granted
at the first court hearing is
extraordinary
i think the judge and the government
attorney
were affected by the fact that there was
so much community support
for mr garcia and media attention on the
case i think it helped
after three weeks in jail he was free
again
at 11 o'clock tonight the family finally
reunited but as you can imagine
it's been a long few weeks for them when
he called out my name
the first time he was arrested it was
like i was called to
finish this like to help them and once
everything got resolved it was like i
could be the guy
mr garcia's case is just one example
of many where people who are
members of our community hard workers
have been picked up by ice and targeted
for reasons that are beyond
comprehension for most americans
donald trump ran for president on the
promise of ridding the country of
illegal immigrants
we will begin removing the more than two
million
criminal illegal immigrants from the
country five days after being sworn in
as president he began making good on
that promise by signing an executive
order directing ice to begin targeting
all removable aliens living in the
country
the department of homeland security
followed suit by releasing a memo
rescinding much of the discretion that
ice agents prosecutors and judges were
previously allowed to exercise in
prosecuting cases
the administration has basically
unshackled ice
given it free reign to do whatever it
wants and said no group
is off limits alex narasti is an
immigration policy analyst at the cato
institute he says the administration's
policies are an escalation of what began
during the obama years
when obama came into office and until
2012
he was rightfully known as the deporter
in chief he basically broke every
deportation record
no matter how you measure it now
beginning about 2012 he started to roll
it back
the deportation numbers are still not up
to what they were
for the first several years of the obama
administration
and it's my prediction they never will
get up there
again while arrests at the border have
actually decreased since trump took
office
ice arrests from the interior of the
country increased by
30 percent between 2016 and 2017.
trump's executive order means that
they're basically trying to draft every
police officer in the country and to
beat an immigration enforcer
while also increasing the amount of
power that the federal agents already
have
it's sort of an effort to roll back the
clock in a sense to go
back to the way that immigration
enforcement was during the first
three to four years of the obama
administration and
uh to really go back to that deporter in
chief mode
matkins also represents sergio kiros a
23 year old man who came over the border
with his mother when he was seven months
old
and has lived in the u.s ever since as a
kid i mean
i knew i came from hispanic parents and
the family you know but
i felt like i was american you know
because my first language was english
kiros now a college student ran into
trouble with immigration enforcement
after getting into a fight with his
ex-girlfriend in 2017.
he says he grabbed and threw her iphone
his court disposition
says he admitted to unlawfully and
willfully touching another person which
qualifies as simple battery the
misdemeanor itself
is not a deportable offense but ice has
increasingly used what are called
detainers to pick up
undocumented immigrants like kiros from
local jails
i was in county for a month
approximately
and after that when i was getting
released the same night immigration came
for me and
took me down to san diego to the federal
i was just like
very overwhelmed because there's been
guys in there that have been for like 10
years that's why
so many states and localities do not
cooperate with ice detainers
they see ice detainers as a way to cast
a wide net to arrest people who should
not be deported
kiros is now in removal proceedings and
has to do regular check-ins with ice
when i think about getting deported i
would have to live with the doubt and
fear that
i may get executed or robbed or
something may happen to me out there
because i'm just i'm
a complete stranger it's pretty scary
would be repelled by the sense that if
somebody was accused of shoplifting
say 20 worth of merchandise and their
punishment would be
to be removed from the country that they
know and love
to be separated from all their human
relationships and their property we'd
all realize that that was a grossly
disproportionate punishment
to the offense and that is exactly what
i'd say about this
the administration often talks about
cracking down on criminals and dangerous
gangs like
ms-13 these are animals they're coming
into our country we're getting them out
they come in again we're getting them
out so garcia's arrest shows just how
little ice has to do and how little the
actual threat
from illegal immigrants is from a
national security and public safety
perspective that they have to target
somebody
who has a 17 year old offense that they
have to target folks like him
shows just how safe the situation is and
how small the public safety
threat is from immigrants when trump got
into office
he made it seem like he was going after
the cartels the
drug lords the gang members and
everything and
who he's actually going after and what
he's doing he's deceiving his
own supporters to be honest with you and
mr trump he's got to change his policy
he's got to do something about it i
still like this man i thought
he was going to do a better job but he's
don't he don't do it to this point he's
not doing a good job
ice officials declined interview
requests for the story
but noraste says the justice
department's policy of removing
discretion from ice agents
prosecutors and judges has exacerbated
the problems of america's over-taxed
immigration system
the administration is trying to charge
anyone it possibly can with an
immigration offense
and the maximum offense possible the
problem with this is that this clogs up
the court systems dramatically i mean
there are almost 800 000 court
cases pending in the immigration courts
prior to
jeff sessions earlier in 2018 announcing
that they were going to prosecute every
border crosser so the likely numbers now
are probably above a million in terms of
the backlog cases
the problem with that is that the courts
are so backlogged that they can't really
clear anything
so even if ice arrests a lot of people
they're going to be sending immigration
attention
they're going to be out there on bonds
they're going to be out there with ankle
bracelets
so they're really just not going to be
able to ramp up this deportation machine
several prominent democrats have called
for the complete abolition of ice
which has existed since 2003 in order
for us to feel safer in our streets
our churches our schools and our homes
we must abolish ice
i believe you should get rid of it start
over reimagine it
the abolish ice movement is mostly just
an optical one
of propaganda and phrase and slogan
the problem is if you abolish ice now
and you do not change any of the other
immigration laws on the books
another law enforcement agency is just
going to do the same thing
they're going to do it in probably about
the same way and you've really
accomplished
nothing rather than focusing on ice
narasta suggests abolishing actual
immigration crimes
such as illegal border crossings and
treating such an
act like a civil infraction akin to a
parking ticket
rather than a criminal offense and he
advocates abolishing enforcement and
removal operations or ero
a division of ice two-thirds of ero's
arrests are for non-criminal offenses
or victimless crimes abolishing ero
would leave interior enforcement duties
with homeland security investigations
or hsi which he says should only focus
on violent criminals
and national security threats doing that
won't abolish ice but what it will do
is get rid of the worst parts of ice
and preserve the portions that i think
should exist 100
of ice resources should be focused on
removing national security violent and
property criminals
abolishing ero and focusing entirely on
hsi would accomplish that goal
sergio kiros and his mother continue to
fight his removal order
as for jose garcia he's back with his
family but plans to finally obtain
full citizenship to protect himself
going forward
to me this is my country and i love it
and i
want to stay here for the longest i can
i want to be buried over here when the
time comes